what do you think of when you hear the
word war is it this or maybe this well
there's a different type of war you may
have heard a lot about recently trade
war worries igniting is a trade war back
on trade war trade war full-blooded
trade all the weapons in a trade war are
everywhere it's the food you eat the
Train you write to work and the laptop
you're probably watching this video on
as a consumer you're probably consuming
imports if we have a trade war and we
start slapping tariffs on all of those
imports the bill is gonna be higher if
the world relies so much on trade what
is a trade war and why do countries get
caught up in them in the first place
all right global trade can be a dry
topic so let's jazz this up a little bit
to avoid any spoilers let's say it's
season one of Game of Thrones and both
the Tyrell and the Lannister kingdoms
manufacturer googly eyes the Tyrells
then start to subsidize googly-eye
manufacturing in their kingdom that
basically means that the Tyrells are
paying at least part of the cost of
manufacturing reducing the cost for
buyers the Lannisters are understandably
upset why would anyone want to buy their
more expensive product they could try
and negotiate with the Tyrells or they
could choose to impose tariffs taxes on
imports that raise the cost of those
goods which in this case would punish
the Tyrells with the tariffs in place if
the Tyrells tried to export goods to the
Lannisters they'd have to pay an extra
tax the Tyrells could then impose
tariffs of their own now if this
disagreement goes back and forth and
escalates with even more tariffs that
would be considered a trade war
but trade wars aren't fiction and
there's more than one way they can start
one possibility is you want to keep out
of country's imports so that your
domestic competitors have an edge a
second possibility is if there's a
country that's doing something that you
don't want them to you can use a tariff
as a way of inflicting a degree of pain
of economic pain on that country and you
say until you change your evil ways I'm
gonna make it hurt okay
so who wins a trade war one way to think
about who wins a trade war is looking at
which country has more targets to choose
from the more goods you shipped to
another country the more vulnerable your
goods are to punishing tariffs so some
economists would say that the country
would ships fewer goods to the other has
an advantage and can outlast the other
in a big clash trade wars can also boost
the fortunes of countries that stand
outside the fray in the 1930s the US
enacted the smoot-hawley Tariff Act
which put into place steep sweeping
tariffs on imports as a way to protect
American workers and industries Canada
and some European countries put up
tariffs of their own launching a trade
war some of these countries then abandon
the US as a trading Ally and took their
trading elsewhere Soviet Russia a
country not involved in the trade war
ended up gaining trading partners as a
result of smoot-hawley so sometimes
countries not involved in a trade war
can benefit from one but as is the case
with most wars trade Wars are harmful
for almost everyone involved
particularly for poorer consumers rising
prices in a trade war can have ripple
effects when people have to spend more
money on basics like clothing it means
they have less money to spend on other
goods and services and that can dampen
the pace of the economy so initially
when you've looked at trade protection
we often put higher protection on goods
that are consumed by poor people there
are economists who have documented that
systematically you tend to find higher
tariffs on things like low-end clothing
shoes sugar which are played a
disproportionate role and the spending
of people who are less well-off
in April President Trump unveiled a list
of over a thousand Chinese exports
things like aircraft parts TVs and
medical devices that he plan to place
tariffs on as a way to punish Beijing
for restricting US investment in China
and for stealing American intellectual
property the very next day
China struck back unveiling its own list
of US exports that it planned to place
tariffs on since then Trump has
threatened another round of tariffs with
China ready to respond with its own
additional tariffs the whole situation
is starting to look a lot like a trade
war countries disagree on fair and
unfair trade practices all the time but
there's something unique about Trump's
approach to it the unpredictability the
wild threats the dissenters and even
pretending to play by the rules Trump
isn't just destabilizing trade relations
with China or any other country he
threatens he's destabilizing the entire
global system of trade
thanks for watching and thanks to
Principal Financial for sponsoring Vox
video whether it's securing your
investments retirement or insurance
protection they can help you plan and
prepare for the unexpected